good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director here at long now and
as many of you know we do a long short
before these talks a short film that
exemplifies long term thinking in some
way and well we were thinking about
which which film to do for a talk about
the Anthropocene the manmade planet the
the images of of the Earth from space of
course are well known more recently the
images of the Earth from space at night
really show the amount of human
interaction on the planet but even more
recently than that are the time lapses
that were shot from the ISS that
probably some of you have seen but these
images were shot with a high dynamic
range low-light camera and took place on
the ISS just a few months ago and in
fact this was such an appropriate
long-short that I've heard that we've
actually overlapped some of our speakers
material tonight so you might see some
of this later in the talk as well go
ahead and roll it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening Ida Stuart brand from long
now foundation how's the sounds we
aren't know it's interesting talk about
the Anthropocene you're not only seeing
tremendous about of humanity blasting
light up from the surface of the earth
there but who's that looking down on
those continents and taking those
pictures where everywhere I'm sometimes
referred to as an environmentalist but
when I encounter somebody like Linus I
figured you know I'm actually sort of a
hobbyist there was a bit of an
environmental sideline of the whole
earth catalogue and I was trained in
ecology once long ago this is the real
deal this is a guy who's been an
activist all his life wrote one of the
best of the climate books fairly early
on when it was still a subject being
raised six degrees and I think one of
the reasons that his country England is
acting more sensibly these days in
relation to climate taking it on at the
scale but it needs to be taken on one of
the reasons that's happening there more
than other places is because mark Lynas
is getting the word out getting listened
and getting acted on please welcome from
Oxford England mark Lynas
[Applause]
well thank you very much indeed Stuart
for that
now given the occasion given the
audience given the place I thought I'd
better start with my clock of the long
now so here we are and what I think is
really striking and so easy to forget is
just how long the earth has been a
living planet for 3.7 billion years so
actually the majority of the planets
very existence and how life is persisted
throughout this whole time despite her
what is it 30% heating up of the Sun is
testament to the some kind of miracle of
self regulation right and that used to
be known by drug-crazed hippies like
Stewart down there as Gaia Gaia theory
and the polite term to use now in
society is system science so just
whisper Gaia but it's the same thing
and somehow throughout this whole time
life got itself involved in all of the
major cycles of renewal and recycling
that make the earth so different from
our neighboring dead planets Venus and
Mars and so living organisms the
biosphere actively participates in the
cycling of carbon nitrogen water
phosphorus sulfur and a whole host of
other things and in doing so somehow
maintains the capacity of the biosphere
to thereby support life itself and
maintain relative stability over these
eons these whole eons of geological
times are long now now let's
fast-forward to a more recent era the
last hundred thousand years now we've
been around as anatomically modern Homo
sapiens for a bit longer than this and I
think our fully modern form really only
emerges in the last 10,000 years because
this is when we have this huge cultural
great leap forward of the emergence of
civilization
of course and it's no accident that this
happens during the very stable
temperatures of the Holocene because if
you see that the sawtooth rollercoaster
ride of what went before that during the
depths of the last ice age this is the
ice core record and just look how much
the earth temperature fluctuates and you
can't imagine civilization coming into
existence on a planet with these rapid
swings in fact this cold event here was
associated probably with the explosion
of an enormous volcano and the near
wiping out of humanity itself reducing
us to just a thousand or so in battled
survivors well we've made a bit of a
comeback since then we're now about what
is it seven over seven billion strong
huge evolutionary success story in less
than half a million years we've gone
from prodding and hills with sticks to
building a worldwide digital
communications network which isn't it's
pretty good going really so a round of
applause for any humans here today no
yeah great job people well done but but
there's a small problem in doing this
and in achieving this evolutionary feat
we've had to capture between a quarter
and a third of the entire photosynthetic
productive capacity of the planet per
year that's the net primary production
and as byproducts of this of course
we're raising the temperature of the
earth system reducing the alkalinity of
the oceans altering the chemistry of the
atmosphere increasing the albedo of the
surface changing the reflectivities of
the planet and changing the distribution
of fresh water and last but not least
changing the species that share the
planet with us over this time so the
Holocene is over and welcome to the
Anthropocene our very uniquely human
geological era now needless to say this
new geological era brings certain
dangers namely that we could cross
tipping points right thresholds if you
like which could tip it into a very
different state an unstable state a
different state from the climatic
stability to name one that's
civilizations come about because of and
when Jim Hanson says that if we burn all
the fossil fuels will turn
this planet into Venus I don't know
whether he's right or wrong but I don't
want to run the risk of finding out so
we know there's likely to be tipping
points in many of these different
systems and we want to stay in this off
safe operating space back from the we
don't know where this is quantified
exactly so there's a zone of uncertainty
and so taking a reasonably precautionary
approach to managing the planet involves
trying to do our very best
scientifically to understand the
possible hard-wired boundaries in the
Earth's system and that's what I mean
when we when I say that whether the god
species and we've got to stay in this
safe operating space and I should say
that I'm indebted to Professor Johan
rock Strom and his team of planetary
boundary scientists who originally
published the paper in Nature in 2009 on
which all of this work is based so let's
go through them one by one first off
biodiversity I put this at the top
because I'm a climate person and I want
to I wanted a bit of a change but also I
think arguably it's the most important
boundary and it's probably the most
difficult one to manage we've poisoned
out completed or simply eaten so many
other species in their entirety that we
now know the Earth's in its greatest
mass extinction events for 65 million
years since the end of the Cretaceous
and I really don't think you can
overstate the urgency of tackling this
problem every year the red list of
endangered species adds more names to
its roster what is it a quarter of
mammals a third of amphibians six of
Birds quarter of corals quarter of
freshwater fish threatened with
extinction currently and it's not just
entire species it's the global abundance
of these animals the abundance of
vertebrates fell by third over the last
40 years so that's a third fewer wild
animals showing the planet with us
there's more Homo sapiens babies added
to the earth every single day than the
entire remaining populations of great
apes those are the bonobos the
chimpanzees the orangutangs and the
gorillas so does I ask the question does
the Anthropocene have to be a zero-sum
game where it's us or them and I really
don't think it does and I don't think
even morally that this one species of
ape
selves has the right to capture so much
of the earth productivity just for
itself and I think also that science
shows that we need to retain the
complexity of biodiverse ecosystems
if they continue if they are to continue
to support the biosphere to support
ourselves by implication and to protect
the resilience of the earth as a living
system hence the proposed boundary which
we've overshot massively perhaps by a
hundred times or more so how do we
improve things well I think we've got to
somehow integrate nature into the
productive economy and perhaps through
payments Rico system services there's
many examples of how they can work very
well I think we need to also scale up
biodiversity offsets so that those who
are doing big projects to pay for can
pay for conservation measures of equal
value somewhere else these these things
are all problematic but there's apt
there's no easy way to to get past this
boundary let's move on to climate change
of course we all know that global
warming didn't stop in 1998 or didn't
stop any more than that stopped in all
the previous occasions when global
warming stopped such as in 1973 1982 to
1987 and 1995 add them all together and
you get this long term trend in rising
temperatures which of course is what
everyone's talking about interesting as
well if the planet were actually cooling
it would be very problematic to explain
thermodynamically how that could even be
the case given that we know the increase
in greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
and we know that the radiative forcing
is increased as a result of that so
you'd have to figure out where all this
extra energy which we know is being
trapped in the earth system where it's
even going you'd have to be able explain
that now that's not to say that we know
everything we we don't know how exactly
how sensitive the earth system is to
increase greenhouse gases we don't know
the precise magnitude of all the Vosges
feedbacks and it sure as hell true that
the computer models projecting future
temperatures get things wrong I think
the most serious error so far is the
enormous underestimate of the rate of
Arctic sea ice melt now according to
people who know their stuff to save the
Arctic ice from complete disappearance
we need a boundary in the atmosphere of
350 parts per million this was a line
which was crossed if you look down at
the graph of this is the Keeling curve
famous graph so where we crossed that
boundary in about 1988 now we're
currently at 3 9 1 so we're way over
this boundary 350 in the longer term
probably the bare minimum you need to
retain the long term integrity of the
major land-based ice sheets which are
obviously the ones which are important
for sea level rise so there's a lot of
nations which depend on this and you
probably all know about 350.org the
campaign group kudos to them and what
this means in terms of a pathway though
is the entire human economy becoming
carbon neutral essentially by 2050 and
carbon negative thereafter and I don't
think anyone's got a technical economic
or even political program for how we can
achieve that but we're going to have to
throw every single thing that we've got
at it let's move on to boundary number 3
here's an interesting story at the turn
of the 20th century a whole lot of
eminent scientists were seriously
alarmed at the prospects of feeding
humanity with the diminishing supply of
natural fertilizer which was available
to scrape out of the Chilean deserts so
this was at some in about 1900 but they
didn't retreat into Malthusian ism and I
kind of make peak oil style predictions
of imminent doom still less come up for
with with schemes brittle schemes for
rationing guano or anything like that
instead they set themselves a challenge
to solve this problem entirely through
the application of technology and to
quote William Crookes who was president
of the British Association said in a
very famous speech in nineteen and sorry
1898 as mouths multiply food resources
dwindle it is the chemists who must come
to the rescue of the threatened
communities it's through the laboratory
that starvation may ultimately be turned
into Plenty now I imagine how
unfashionable it would be to say such
things today in environmental circles a
techno fix how vulgar vulgar
but some William Crookes was right
because within just over a decade from
him making that speech these two
gentlemen had indeed solved the problem
of nitrate shortage in 1912 which is why
you know who they are can you shout them
out Haber and Bosch have on the Left
Bosch on the right and due to their
invention of the synthesizing of
atmospheric nitrogen into ammonia we now
have a population which can reach 7
billion without it we'd probably be at
1.5 billion or something humans by the
way the only species along with
Rhizobium bacteria that have learned to
fix nitrogen which is quite an
interesting thing having achieved this
capacity we've doubled the terrestrial
nitrogen cycle so we put huge amounts of
this nutrient into into water courses in
coastal ocean oceans where it's causing
algal blooms dead zones like in the Gulf
of Mexico in an average year the Gulf of
Mexico dead zones at 20,000 square
kilometers now to protect biodiversity
to protect freshwater ecosystems we're
going to have to according to the
proposal reduced our amounts of
consumption from 120 million of nitrogen
two times to 235 million how do we do
that I really have no idea and I think
that's going to be much more challenging
so you know carbon is a doddle compared
to this because nitrogen is a biological
necessity you can't substitute it for
something else so what what could we do
where we could take a leaf out of
William Crookes his book from 1898 and
look for a new techno fix which would
enable crop plants to either use what we
put on the land much more efficiently or
even fix their own nitrogen which only
legumes do at the moment and I'll come
back to one way of how we might do that
later on I'd give you a hint it's
something that greens don't want to
swallow over that one all right
land use so why can't we solve the
nitrogen problem just by going organic
well because as I said if we did that
we'd either have to watch more than half
the population starve all we'd have to
double the amount of land under
cultivation and land itself
is a boundary why is that well
habitat is the most precious resource
for biodiversity if we give up intensive
farming we might save some oil but we'd
probably have to ply up all the
rainforest to keep feeding people so
already the Anthropocene means that 85%
of the Earth's surfaces fragmented or
substantially affected by human
activities so there's this is what
happened to the old geographical your
old geography textbook biomes have
turned into the ant roams of the
anthropogenic era I think there's a
general principle that if we are to feed
9.5 billion by 2050 we're going to have
a serious problem of doing that without
going way over the land-use boundary
assuming you accept that that figure
again we're gonna have to throw
everything in the toolbox at solving
this problem in biodiversity terms I
think there's a fairly clear general
principle coming out of the literature
which is that land sparing is better
than land sharing so you want the
smallest possible area devoted to the
most intensive possible cultivation and
really to leave the rest alone was far
alone as you possibly can and the place
is to really focus on to really protect
to the biodiversity hotspots which
Harbor something like half the world's
species in just 1.4 percent of the land
area it's extraordinary then I'll
conclude this by saying I think one of
the dumbest ideas of all is using food
crops to make biofuels and I think
there's substantial agreement on this
point now even clearly clue from you to
thank you and I I do I feel this very
strongly that it's a moral as well as an
ecological outrage that 40% of the u.s.
corn crop which could be spent feeding
people is wasted on ethanol production
and I think it's true to say that tens
of millions people are hungry today
because of this pork barrel politics now
agriculture needs water as well as land
and globally 60% of the world's largest
200 or so rivers have been fragmented by
man-made infrastructure that's 800,000
dams large and small people say we can't
do big things rapidly we've built I
think it's two large dams per day over
the
last half-century half of those have
been in China alone by the way here in
the Colorado this is the Hoover Dam of
course you know I think I think if this
is less of a river than as a sort of
semi natural remaining part of a
gigantic plumbing hydro hydro engineered
plumbing system serving the needs of 30
million people in the southwest United
States but how much of the water reaches
the sea along this hundred one thousand
four hundred mile river and not a lot
and that's put paid to a flourishing
area of biodiversity down there in the
in the estuary which is now ruined but
and of course humanity overall needs a
lot more clean water billion people
worldwide still lack access to improve
water supplies and actually people talk
about the impacts of climate change if
we were to deliver clean water to the
whole of the world's population most of
the deaths which are attributed to
climate change now would disappear
that's because they come from from from
increased bacterial load in slightly
warmer bad water supplies now we've got
to share the rivers though with the rest
of the biosphere these are the blue
arteries of the Living Planet and it's
no accident the extinction rate for
freshwater species is five times higher
than terrestrial species in general
looking at the boundary and you know you
can argue and I think there's some merit
in arguing that a quantified global
total doesn't make a whole lot of sense
it depends where you take the water from
and what the river system has in terms
of its own precipitation but we're well
over halfway there for this one now what
can we do about it well I think one of
the most important things to do is to
remove the superfluous dams and where
this has been done in some rivers in the
US I think we should celebrate that and
particularly how rapidly they flourished
back into life how the fish have
returned I also think we need to accept
that electric that hydroelectricity as a
energy source of energy production is
basically maxed out as well for this
reason and also don't forget virtual
water that's why eating locally isn't
always the best thing to do certainly
not if you live in Egypt which imports
5.8 billion cubic meters of water
in its wheat imports every single year
that's 10% of equivalent to what the
country uses temp center what the
country uses so we need to produce food
where water's most abundant does less
does the least ecological damage and in
total the world food través saves 500
cubic kilometers a virtual water per
year by by this efficiency trade-off
which is a substantial contribution to
that to that boundary of course those
are all quantified boundaries they have
numbers attached to them with which the
scientists are proposed as what we
humans have to observe in terms of the
safe operating space our results doesn't
this is an unquantified boundary because
literally the behavior of all these
different particles from all these
different sources in all these different
places in the atmosphere is so damn
complicated in using talking about air
pollution of course I had to use a
picture of China there on the right in
Beijing they don't announce muggy days
they announced blue skies days because
those are the unusual ones and it's not
just Asia you know that's the asian
brown cloud there on the left running up
against the himalayas when all those
particles have sort fall out on the snow
they make it melt faster and that is
aggravating the rate of glacial melt and
global warming of course overall I think
it's just been estimated in the UK alone
that 30,000 people die early because of
atmospheric pollution 4,000 a year in
London in China of course it's a lot
more I think it's true to say if we had
a rational or statistical approach to
risk you would evacuate people out of
London or Tokyo and move them into the
Fukushima exclusion zone they'd live
longer if you did that look if you
believe the statistics globally the
aerosol pollution death toll is
estimated at 1.5 million people per year
that's at Chernobyl every single hour so
we're going to have to take this
pollution out of the atmosphere for
simple health reasons and we will do so
and the Chinese are already cleaning up
their coal-fired power stations for this
very reason because people want to be
able to see the sky and they want their
kids to survive now that's going to give
an extra boost to global warming because
most most of these particles have a
cooling effect so one of the are not
saying proposals but one of us sort of
thought experiments I proposed in the
book is that we could move this
pollution cooling pollution from the
troposphere where
have to breathe it up into the
stratosphere where it can still call the
planet but nobody has to breathe it
that's called you engineering however
and this of course necessarily
controversial we can come back to that
if you like another unquantified
boundary is this idea of toxic pollution
of course this was the origin in
environmentalism in many ways with
Rachel Carson's book and I think one of
the clearest features of the
Anthropocene is how we've synthesized
novel molecules not seen in nature and
which can't be easily degraded by
bacteria or whatever in the environment
and the impacts can be catastrophic
there was a case not long ago in India
where dick raffinate which I've
sometimes taken for a bad back when it's
in cattle carcasses has killed something
like 99.9 percent of the populations of
different vultures there and possibly
it's an it's a factor in amphibian
declines as well also a lot of these
toxic bio accumulate in the food chain
they end up in the Arctic one of the
newcomers in the Arctic the old ones
have PCBs and Mercury things like that
one of the new ones is cadmium and you
find that in cadmium telluride solar
panels amongst other places so you know
people talk about nuclear waste I think
we've got to talk about solar waste as
well you know we're going to build a new
Yucca Mountain for all of the waste
that's going to come out of solar panels
that doesn't make any sense what we have
to do is recycle it and we have to make
the same thing for any of these toxics
speaking of nuclear waste this is where
they'd come in right if you wanted to
talk about nuclear waste or radiate
radioactive pollution as a problem it's
going to come in this planetary boundary
and the problem is though and I've
looked into this quite deeply that with
the exception of the immediate area
around Chernobyl I've not been able to
find any indication of radioactive
pollution affecting biodiversity in any
meaningful way and in fact of course the
Chernobyl exclusion zone where have been
myself is a by and large a flourishing
wildlife zone so I think it's probably
true to say that the this great unsolved
supposedly unsolved problem of nuclear
waste hasn't so far harmed a single
living being and if you know of any case
in the scientific literature that says
otherwise tell me and I will stop making
that statement I've made that statement
many times and no one's come up
anything so far now what about this
boundary here ocean acidification this
is sort of the evil twin of of climate
change of global warming we can't fix
this with geoengineering cooling the
planet is going to make any difference
to the rate at which carbon dioxide
dissolves into the oceans and we release
humanity releases a million tons of
carbon per hour we've dug up since the
beginning of the Anthropocene since
James Watt invented the steam engine in
1784 we've dug up half a trillion tons
of carbon and burnt it and most of
that's gone into the oceans where via
that equation there it has turned them
less alkaline and more acidic as a
result so that sees us something like
30% more acidic or less alkaline at the
beginning of the Anthropocene and if we
don't do something to halt this trend
well we're going to see tropical coral
reefs dissolving globally by around
mid-century and the Cal serious plankton
there at the base is the very basis of
the marine food chain are going to
disappear gradually as well
turning the oceans gradually from blue
to green this is what's been called
elsewhere the rise of slime by the way
there's a huge amount of geological
evidence that high high periods of co2
emission in the distant past many
hundreds of millions of years ago of
closely associated with reef gaps in the
fossil record so this is these appears
when coral reef ceased to exist globally
because probably there has been major
acidification events in the in the
geological past and I've looked I've
looked through the geology literature
for the last half billion years for the
last five hundred million years and I
can't find a single episode which comes
anything close to the rate at which we
are emitting carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere so that's quite a amazing
thing to find out as a boundary proposed
in that which we are running up closely
against now I want to end the boundaries
bit however with the solitary and most
obvious good news story anyone know who
that chap is by the way he's less well
known than and Fritz Haber and Carl
Bosch but he shouldn't be no
he-hey I got you now I'm gonna wait to
have another 10 minutes till he come out
with him hey that's not my diet he's
comes up elsewhere
this is Thomas Midgley loyal servants of
the General Motors Corporation back in
the 1920s he's got two inventions to his
credit one is the addition of tetraethyl
led to petrol to stop engine knocking
the other was the invention of CFCs so
in the words of John McNeil who's a
historian Thomas Midgley probably had
more impact on the atmosphere than any
other single organism in Earth history
now when he invented these everyone was
very grateful because CFCs seemed like a
miracle they're non reactive non
combustible didn't have any of the
problems that previous refrigerants had
had but that's only in the troposphere
no one bothered to see what happened in
the stratosphere when they get hit by
eltra violet radiation they split apart
you get free chlorine and that destroys
ozone by the way when NASA first spotted
this some ozone hole there they assumed
it was instrumental error and they spent
years deleting the data files which
showed and you know who discovered it
finally properly that was the Brits down
in there Halley's in their station in
that Antarctic base so brand reports
were ready many Brits here in the
audience say oh yeah
of course this is our one a big success
story because we've managed to through
the application of international
treaties through the Vienna Convention
then Montreal Protocol reduce the
production of CFCs right down to that
both in developed and developing
countries almost faded out completely
what are the lessons here I think
there's three really crucial ones one it
helps that the United States is on the
right side a lot and believe it or not
this was the Reagan administration that
took this forward and the US Senate was
the second in the world to sign this
treaty the US Senate signs treaties
right
imagine if they've done this with Kyoto
we've been a very different world today
second the lesson for me is that the
process has to be that politicians set
the path that regulation is the
beginning and then business follows
that's the right order and and there's
there's a very persistent
if by the way that DuPont or whoever it
was developed or got patents on the
substitutes for CFCs and then they gave
permission for the for the politicians
to sign their treaty actually it was the
other way around you prompt and many of
the other producers phased out their
entire substitute programs technical
programs to develop substitutes so the
politicians wouldn't have the option but
they went ahead anyway and they took a
leap of faith and that's when business
then had to turn around and became a
partner for change third lesson tech
technical substitutes the techno fix is
nothing to be ashamed of and I really do
believe that if saving ozone there had
meant giving up refrigeration or even
giving up hairspray we'd all be wearing
dark glasses today and a lot of sunblock
so let's look at the future we've got a
big challenge today in the world we've
got to eliminate poverty and bring
everyone up to the Western levels of
consumption by 2050 and we've got to do
that within the planetary boundaries
right why because people across the
whole world want and have the right to
live lives free from want now I'm going
to show you some graphs here of the flip
side of the Anthropocene and of how
fantastic our miracle of human progress
and prosperity has been I'm gonna start
with this one here oh you vent any of
you familiar with these graphs they're
produced by an outfit called
gapminder.org yeah and superb superb
this is Hans Rosling he's given some TED
talks and this is about making data come
alive he's got this amazing things so
here on the Left I've got life
expectancy right you can see going for
25 up to 80 or so the year is 1800 they
are all the countries the size of the
dot is the size of the population there
is income per person GDP per capita and
if we as we run the graph forward we're
going to watch how global development
happens remembers the UK who's in the
lead at very back because the UK had the
Industrial Revolution at first and you
can see how life expectancy goes up and
down that's probably because different
countries are having wars a different
time if we watch closely now when these
are these orange countries of the
European countries watch the first world
war there it goes down it down everyone
goes watch now in the 1940s look at the
is China over here watch the Great Leap
Forward sit down it goes that's when all
those people die with that terrible
experiment of communism but in general
you can see how all the clustering moves
all of the world's countries up in that
in that general direction and who is in
Afghanistan today he's got a life
expectancy of 44 that's the worst
if we rewind the clock back to 1800
who's the worst there so you know the
United Kingdom is the best by the way
and that's 40 so even though the richest
country in 1800 has a worst life
expectancy than the poorest country does
today and that's not of course because
everybody lives to this averages because
of child mortality so many children
didn't survive to see their fifth
birthday I'm going to show you one more
of these just to show how important this
relationship is that we've only got data
from one country in 1800 and that's
Sweden but if we push this forward I'll
make it move a bit faster here you can
see how child mortality is beginning to
drop here as countries get richer and
there's quite a strong relationship
which really begins to form you can see
that's the u.s. by the way in yellow
down there and look at all these
countries - how they begin to cluster
right down there at the bottom so we've
now got child mortality right down a
very low level 3/4 when before it was
300-400 you know so by two orders of
magnitude it's really a miracle that
we've managed to do this if I make the
this side logarithmic rather than linear
right so that's 600 there that's 2 down
here you can see the relationship a bit
more clearly even between between GDP
and the survival of children so this is
why I'm a supporter of GDP because I'm a
parent and I've got young kids and I
think every other parent around the
world should be able to have their young
children survive into adulthood and
losing a child as as anyone knows is
probably the worst thing that can ever
happen in your life now this is where
the Malthusian spark company from the
Malthusians like to talk about carrying
capacity
and I think what's missing from this is
the fact that carrying capacity is a
moving target if if everyone was to live
the lifestyle of a hunter-gatherer the
earth could probably support about 100
million people right and given the
haber-bosch Revolution then we could
support more than 3 billion people 7
billion people thanks to the Industrial
thanks to the Green Revolution rather
and Norman Borlaug so I want to continue
this miracle so we've got this problem
with environmental resource limits but
how can we continue the miracle of human
development the increasing rate of GDP
growth for the countries who so far
missed out on the needs to reduce infant
mortality rates so dramatically that's
the big challenge today now one of the
ways that we're doing this is through
urbanization 2008 as you probably know
was a really momentous year because
that's when we had more people living in
cities than in the countryside shout out
the numbers here India 2030 how many
cities are we going to see sixty-eight
China how many were going to see 221
eight what is it a hundred eighty
thousand people move to the cities each
day one hundred and eighty thousand
people each day now why is that because
in cities people get wealthier quicker
they exchange experiences that exchange
ideas they exchange materials cities are
engines of innovation and their engines
of growth and that's why cities have
largely diffused the population bomb and
if such a thing was ever true let's look
at fertility changes during urbanization
here one more graph just to prove this
case we're back in 1960 here there's the
US the China there's India Japan is that
these remember these orange countries
are European ones there isn't such a
strong correlation there's this is sort
of a line through it but it's not that
strong get stronger though as you move
time onwards countries for look how
rapidly China Falls with its one-child
program and they're still urbanizing
gradually moving towards that right so
it's almost like a sort of rain of
countries all heading down here towards
an urbanized outcome and a relatively
low fertility rate
in fact if you look at this globally
people really don't don't appreciate how
rapidly the the rate of fertility has
declined globally and in hands Rosling
actually did a poll a live poll at the
American Association for the Advancement
of science where they're supposed to be
smart people and they got it wrong by
they I think they guessed it was
something like 3.5 and it's actually 2.5
today and that's dropped from five
children per per woman in 1960 and so in
fact we're now at peak child right
people tell at peak oil we're at peak
child we're not gonna see any more
absolute numbers of children in the
world ever we're at two billion children
the level has stopped growing what else
is important
I mentioned intensification or
agriculture before 13 percent of the
world population is still undernourished
we've got to in keep on improving
productivity we've got to keep on the
Green Revolution that means ignoring
people like Vandana Shiva who wrote that
and I'm indebted to Stuart for finding
this and I heard this from Google books
just to show that it's real this perhaps
the stupidest ever sentence written by
somebody who claims to know about
biology which is the idea that sterility
is going to spread and this is the whole
myth of the Terminator gene and a whole
bunch of other things which are still
the basis I find to most anti GMO
activism and norm have ball out the
father of the Green Revolution spent the
last years of his life campaigning
against the
technophobia which is so prevalent in
the environmental movement because he
wanted his revolution to continue
through the improvement of crop
varieties look what he says if the
naysayers do manage to stop agricultural
biotechnology they might actually
precipitate the famines and the crisis
of global biodiversity they've been
predicting for nearly 40 years
whether you're Paul Ehrlich or whether
you're an anti Monsanto activist you
should listen to one that goes saying by
the way one last graph and this is to
show the linkages between agricultural
land and food supply to show the
increase in productivity and what it
does in terms of you'd expect those we
produce more food we're going to be
using more land and that's partly the
case I've highlighted some of the
countries here so you can see the trend
over long over longer period
from 1960s onwards that's an what's that
that's the US so the u.s. is actually
cultivating less land overall to produce
vast quantities more food and the same
goes for that's China that that's is
that China or Brazil that's China down
there look at that's India so these
lines are almost flat as they go from
left to right we're producing huge
quantities more food to feed the buzz
population on almost the same amount of
land and we've done that because of the
Green Revolution so that's why it's been
an environmental boon in many many ways
now GM crops I think are important to
continue this movement forward they can
improve they can help us with many of
the planetary boundaries they can
improve water use efficiency nitrogen
use efficiency of course land use that's
going to be important as well cultivated
on three billion acres worldwide so far
without a single substantiated case of
health or safety impacts the anti GMO
Lobby who I tangle with quite a lot
these days never tire of repeating this
myth that the whole benefit of GM is
captured only by these big corporations
including the pantomime villain of
months of much as Monsanto and they've
got this idea that farm is a stupid or
being contract into buying these seeds
which aren't giving them the yields and
aren't producing them and aren't making
them money actually it's the opposite
which is the case ten billion dollars
per year of additional benefit to
captured by farmers primarily in the
developing world 90% of GMO farmers are
now in the developing world and just to
put this again in scientific context if
you're into GMO you're on a collision
course with both science and development
this is my very strong message Paul
nurse president of the Royal Society the
most August and scientific body in the
UK if not the world said in his BBC
Dimbleby lecture last week it is not
acceptable if we deny the world's
poorest access to ways that could help
their food security if that denial is
based on fashion and ill informed
opinion rather than good science here's
one that maybe is less controversial but
is equally important perhaps and getting
clean cookstoves to all of the world
poor women who are cooking indoors
in highly polluted environments such as
this and the climate change impact is
going to be beneficial and that's one
way we can pay for it through carbon
offsetting but the levels of toxins in
air like this are hundreds of times
above World Health Organization
standards and the reason that this is so
dangerous is that it kills something
like three people per minute there's
mostly women and children one hundred
eighty per hour 1.6 million per year
that's what we need to do we need to pay
for these things
recycling I'm into recycling because I'm
an environmentalist I think the most
important environmental equation in the
world is e equals mc-squared because it
describes how much energy you can get
from nuclear fission breaking chemical
bonds by the way reduces and produces
trivial amounts of energy compared to
breaking new nuclear bonds compared to
splitting the atom you can get a million
times more energy from a this size of
uranium than you can from this size of
coal now today
16% of the world's electricity comes
from nuclear imagine how much more it
would have been had the anti-nuclear
movement not mobilized in the 1970s and
1980s and stopped with relentless
lawsuits in campaign activities stop
that trend towards clean power and the
upshot of course is today the world is
newly dependent on coal for electricity
production which then results in
possibly tens possibly hundreds of
billions of additional tons of co2
accumulated in the atmosphere than they
would have been otherwise now this is
bad for the climate it's bad for ocean
acidification it's bad for toxics it's
bad for nitrogen it's bad for
biodiversity it's almost every single
planetary boundary which is affected
negatively by coal use now I'm not
saying that all nuclear reactors are
perfect that would be a bit pigheaded
after Fukushima even though that's still
a non fatal accident by the way but
fukushima's boiling water reactors were
designed in the 1960s nuclear technology
hasn't Stood Still since then here's I
think the greenest piece of single piece
of technology ever designed this is the
sodium called fast reactor one variant
of which is the integral fast reactor
I'm quite an enthusiast of that G heater
cheese marketing this as
prism and this was actually designed by
the engineers in argon National
Laboratories to address to specifically
address many of the problems that which
were raised by the anti-nuclear
activists so it's got passive safety it
recycles nuclear waste and it actually
could produce enormous quantities of
energy simply from burning up the spent
fuel stockpiles that we've already got
and this Guardian piece which came out
just in February we did some numbers and
you can get 500 years worth of clean
carbon free power from the existing
nuclear waste stockpile that the UK's
got in the US it's several six or
seventh centuries perhaps even more
simply from burning of uranium-238 most
of the uranium in the current cycle of
nuclear actors is wasted and that I
think is an environmental shame as well
so we can solve the nuclear waste
problem and we can solve climate change
by scaling up 4th generation nuclear
power nuclear power yes please
international treaties this is often
neglected by people but if we're going
to run the planet successfully as a
intelligent species which we claim to be
in our name Homo sapiens we're going to
have to get better at doing these and I
spend a lot of time at Durban where all
of these people are huddling for as a
delegate for the Maldives so I know just
how depressing and grueling these kinds
of experiences actually are so I'm under
no illusions about how easy it is to do
that but I think we've got to try
there's a biodiversity process because
the climate process toxics has been done
or at least addressed Ozone's been done
quite successfully but what about these
other plans for boundaries how are we
going to address them through some kind
of international process there isn't
such a thing so far I think we're going
to need one now let's talk about what's
that
a lot of sleepless nights everyone here
this was about what it was to say 3:00
a.m. on the 11th of December I can
guarantee that almost everyone in that
picture had not slept for three nights
and it slept very little for the
previous week you know you cannot
understand the the sheer physical and
how awful that thing is I'm so glad that
we've had a coup now and I don't have to
work for the Maldives anymore it's not
every day one's boss gets deposed by a
military revolution anyway I'm gonna
finish up soon I want to talk just
finish up a bit with a big picture we've
the challenge shows to use is to recycle
everything and to use a lot less at the
same time as we grow the economy we've
got to increase GDP overall and by two
or three times in order to solve world
poverty this is my illustration of
dematerialization by the way there's
nothing else on this slide so I couldn't
think of anything and the root of this
is some very basic economics which I did
I cannot accept to a level as we call it
in England and I don't know well that is
like fifth grade or sixth grade in the
US system third son anyway I'm not
particularly good at economics but I do
remember that we had this curve called
marginal utility and it levels off it
doesn't go up forever it's not a
exponential increase and what I mean I
thought of a reason why this is if you
don't have a fridge and you live in an
NGO or somewhere that the difference
when you get a fridge is between your
food rotting and being able to feed
yourself for a week or two two fridges
is better because you can have more food
three fridges isn't so great for fridges
you run out of space in your kitchen you
don't really want the things you know
that's what happens when marginal
utility levels off and that's actually
beginning to happen across the economy
in many different ways and in the
developed world we've seen peak travel
already people just simply don't want to
travel more kilometres every single year
and in the UK in fact we've even seen
peak material requirement for the whole
economy including imports and that
happened before the recession so you
know that's a really extraordinary thing
that people don't realize that we can
demonize the economy at the same time as
we can see continuing growth in even in
conventional metrics like like GDP
now I want to if I figure out how to do
this
switch back to this is the reprise if
you like of the video that you saw at
the beginning although we had this
independently I just had this lying
around on my desktop and I like to show
it and the reason I like to show it is
because if you look down at the Earth
from space it's still an extraordinary
extraordinary beautiful planet if not
more beautiful because we brought color
and we brought life light to a viewpoint
which was without it beforehand of
course and we're able to see the planet
from up there and that means that the
planet knows she is beautiful in the
words of James Lovelock and I think you
can see from these here we are flying
over Egypt that's the Nile Delta just
coming up I think you can see
intuitively by looking at this that we
are inherently an indivisibly part of
the earth system where it's so embedded
within it we're as natural as the ant or
the polar bear and what does that mean
well it means it's up to us to fix the
planet's problems most of which we've
caused both of these hands today in the
picture belong to us so that's the god
species and to be very specific that's
me there on the left and that's Stuart
brand down there on the right when he
said we were as gods he just meant the
tur bus you didn't think it was all of
you as well did you anyway
so it's it's up to us to determine the
temperature of the earth system in
decades to come the the chemistry of the
atmosphere in the oceans and we've got
to decide how much of living ecosystems
to protect in their resilient state and
I want to finish up by saying why I'm
fairly unapologetically an optimist and
I don't I don't think I can base this on
any great scientific stuff to be honest
I think it's about faith and the
difference between optimism and
pessimism is that optimists believe that
we can solve problems by doing new
things tomorrow that we can't do today
so we'll have learning we'll have
innovation we'll have improvement
pessimists on the other hand think that
we're going to be more restricted
tomorrow we're going into a more limited
more resource constrained world and were
going to be less able to fix problems
and I'm actually not a scientist I'm a
historian chalking and I can't say who's
right of course but looking
back through Hans Rosling's graphs
looking at the story of the last 200
years I think the lessons of history the
weight of history is with the optimist
thank you very much
I have a specific question on the
integral fast reactors they're using and
present nuclear waste which is stashed
in these dry cast containers out behind
all of the president actor sites but
they don't presumably use up all of the
stuff in there so the waste that comes
out of the IFR how bad or good is it
there's two big benefits one is that you
use up potentially a hundred percent of
the energy in the uranium whereas a
conventional once-through reactor will
use less than one percent and that's
because you're fishing the uranium-238
not just a 235 or not just a portion of
that the second is that what comes out
at the end of the process is fission
products which have a radioactive
lifetime so they go back to the
radioactivity of the original uranium
ore which came out of the planet's
surface within about 200 3 2 3 4 500
years you know that's not the million
year Yucca Mountain time scale and so
you know we can imagine having a
facility which only has to last for 300
years you know there's a lot of
buildings where I come from an oxide
which I have a lot longer than that I'll
give you the question and that all of us
get would you accept the nuclear waste
site near where you live in archery I
would not only accept it over welcoming
and I would take a leaf out of James
Lovelock's book and use the heat to heat
the house
is that a question that's one wrote down
will do no no that's all through in
chios performed she look at these long
questions I've never had this before so
Alexander Rose says well the population
they peak in 2050 same data suggests so
we'll be back down by 2100 is seven
billion or lower how are these
boundaries affected by a declining
population the second half of this
century and then presumably beyond when
we're not looking at this you know
diminishing rate of increase but then an
increasing rate of decrease of humans
can we relax about the boundaries at
that point or what happens I'm not
accustomed to being asked to worry about
declining population well you know
interesting because well what happens is
that you tend to get economic problems
you get a reduction in the rate of
innovation and there's all sorts of
reasons why having a declining
population isn't a good idea socially
and economically conceptually if you've
got fewer people on the planet and we've
all got more resources and that's a good
thing but I don't know this is such a
long way off the population we don't
even know what what the levels going to
be in terms of its peak so 9.5 billion
or so it isn't I don't think it's going
to decline precipitously by into 2100
and what happens post 2100 I really that
would be stupid to you know I'll leave
that to future it's like your boundaries
you're only willing to think a hundred
years you look backwards I'm happy to
look backwards four and a half billion
years I'm gonna have you look forward
about four and a half minutes you know
it's really nothing else is sensible
there's an asymmetry here John Noble
asks although most geoengineering
techniques are controversial one is
important to seriously consider removing
co2 from the atmosphere there's various
ideas about that what's your preference
I don't even call that geoengineering
because it's such a no-brainer and
geoengineering in its politically loaded
sense now is about doing all sorts of
engineering interventions which are
going to have a drastic effect directly
on the Earth's system such as solar
radiation management
I think carbon capture it just makes
makes it so much sense and we are
absolutely going to have to do it one of
the ways we can do that and I think
you've talked about this is biochar you
know you can increase the productivity
of of the Earth's soils by sequestering
elemental carbon in the form of charcoal
that actually by the way affects other
boundaries it retains water and it
increases nitrogen use efficiency so
there's a whole bunch of things that we
can do and that that's a you know
technically that's Jinja nearing I
suppose because it's the question carbon
but we've absolutely got to look at it
how come we keep hearing about how
biochar is gonna be this great things
we've been hearing that 10 or 12 years
now and I keep waiting for some data to
come in wow it's really working I'm so
happy you're all our marginal and is now
really rich and fertile one yeah I mean
you see the pipe dream I don't know but
it's being it tends to be sort of
small-scale thing and if it's going to
work it's got to be done in industrially
we've got to be moving biochar around in
the same way we're moving ammonium
fertilizer and I can't see any pet plant
for that yet are you looking at the sort
of so-called carbon capture from the air
one of the ways that I mean there's
Klaus Lackner artificial trees though I
think the economics of that is always
going to be problematic but it seems to
be going forward you've also we've got
to have ways to put carbon underground
co2 using carbon capture and storage and
that's always a diminishing prospect I
mean it was it was coal and gas we're
going to have CCS by about now according
to the prognostications that were made 5
10 years ago so all the eggs are put in
that basket that's one of the reasons
why nuclear it's got to come strongly
back onto the table because CCS isn't
happening I don't know if it's going to
I think we should put a lot more effort
into making it happen but it's certainly
not going to be the sort of silver
bullet which keeps fossil fuels on the
grid and still solves climate change so
you guys doing all these wonderful
things are they pushing ahead on clean
call I think there was about five or six
projects there's one of them left they
are diminishing it's just so down
expensive because it's going to cost
billions to have the first scaled up CCS
facility which actually puts you know
you'll convince your average coal-fired
power station produces a couple of
million tons of co2 per year that's a
lot that has to go into ground and has
to go underground in the right place in
assay line formation or into an older
oil field or something you can't just
take it anywhere under someone's houses
in fact in in Germany and the Greenpeace
did a map of all the places that were
proposed for CCS and scared the [ __ ] out
of everybody and then CCS is now off to
political table so you can't do nuclear
can't do CCS what's generally going to
do it's going to do more fossil
did I hear you actually say somewhere in
your blog that Greenpeace is now doing
more harm than good
I would never say such a thing I mean
Greenpeace does some great work on on
deforestation they're doing stuff on
palm oil on overfishing there's a whole
bunch of things I wouldn't like to
average it out having said that because
I think Greenpeace has really been a
menace in many ways but it's not just
Greenpeace they just represent one
aspect of the environmental community
and now they're less extreme than many
of the sort of independent activists who
confront me all the time and start
shouting about Monsanto and things
there's anybody pygar you once spied
you're in Lomborg in public he had a
bookstore the problem with the story
here is that Bjorn Lomborg came out with
the book The Skeptical environmentalist
and my activist friend here ambushed him
at a book signing and pied him and went
off ranting something about climate yeah
that's probably the most embarrassing
video ever on the and it's on YouTube
and you can still get it I wish I could
censor it or something but the problem
is that and I'm threatened with buying
all the time these days if anyone does
it I really can't complain you know I
don't have any grounds to say that's an
outrageous physical assault you know
when I've done the thing myself fifteen
years ago you also used to read I'll
take that as an invitation anyone you
also you also used to rip up genetically
engineered plants from research stations
yeah and that's something else I'm not
proud of and but you know you live and
learn and I mean at that time this was
an entirely novel technology and you
could make a plausible case that it
wasn't being it wasn't well enough
understood to put out into the
environment and we've now had ten
fifteen years later pretty good
information that it's not harmful and in
fact there's all sorts of beneficial
applications of GM science which I
wasn't aware of at the time I mean I was
pretty damn ignorant you know I hadn't
read a single scientific paper I didn't
know what GM was even about and and in
fact what changed me was writing climate
change books which I insisted were
strongly scientific and had lots of
references in and then realizing that
I'd never
a single paper on biotechnology nothing
in the scientific literature all I knew
was recycled sort of stuff that was
coming from NGOs you have said that
comments on your blog actually started
to change your mind it must be true no
no no it's comments actually on the
Guardian I wrote a you know how you
newspaper phoned you up and you write a
recycled piece and it takes twenty
minutes you probably know anyway this
this was it yeah but your yeah the last
one last time I ever did that was in
2007 2008 on the Guardian and I think I
even member the title it's called GM
isn't to harvest for the world or
something and under that there was so
many comments mmm pointing out that I
didn't know what I was talking about
I've got quite a thick skin but it's
something a bit of that filter too I
thought yeah actually I don't know what
I'm talking about and what will I do
well I'll shut up for a few years and
actually reading your book was one of
the things that I'd already moved off
the fence and I knew what that my mind
was changing on this but I didn't want
to ever go public and meeting your book
gave me the courage to do that retrained
isn't you were you trained as an
historian or is this sort of what you
are anyway I did only to the extent that
I did politics in modern history
University this I'm trying to figure out
where the hell you learned how to change
your mind i I
I like being wrong because it enables
you to find out new stuff and it's
actually really interesting process
because you think wow this August thing
you know and you start reading and
that's that's just great imagine if you
thought the same thing as you thought 25
years ago like a memory Lovins or
someone it must be really depressing and
boring here's a question from somebody
named January I'm sitting next to
February anyway why isn't there a human
population boundary wouldn't this help
avoid overshooting all the others
because population is a is a driver of
our affect on all the different
boundaries so it's not a it's not the
point of the boundaries is that they're
defined in a in an earth system sense
right so even if humans didn't exist
actually then there is still an ocean
acidification boundary which in fact is
breached and causes mass extinctions in
the geological past because of the rate
of co2 from them from volcanoes over a
long time so the point is about what the
safe operating space is and how we use
technology how we use the words the
world's resources what our level of
consumption is is what then drives our
impact ok level of consumption so you're
this great champion for the poor getting
out of poverty they're billions in that
situation India China and other places
they are going up the food chain they
want to eat meat they want to eat and
they're gradually in town and so on
getting the resources to you so they
want to use a whole lot more electricity
there's more we have building new
coal-fired plants in the u.s. in years
really
but China and India are building new
coal-fired plants all the damn time so
shouldn't we be I know what do you make
of that they have it sounds like I hear
this a lot and you must hear it a lot
well you know it isn't just population
its population that's doing a lot more
consuming that was true it's true but
it's also very simplistic ok it's the
type of consuming that matters and it's
the impacts of that type of consuming
that matters and I think the part of the
equation which is tractable there is
technology and this is why I come back
to the if we live like cavemen you don't
have much technology and if you compare
that to your average industrial farmer
who produces enough to feed an entire
city with one person you know that's
because of purely because of the
technology and the energy fossil energy
whatever energy was coming in as an
input into that an energy is that is
probably the most tractable thing that
we've got we can produce as much energy
as we like using fish and fusion all the
other options that we've got on the
table and we've got to basically
substitute energy for some of these
planetary boundaries so we've got to use
energy to desalinate water in order to
capture less from the world's rivers
we've got to use energy to produce more
food from a small amount of land and
therefore respect the lantry's boundary
have you tracked under desalination very
much and how it works and what the
economies are and so on no I mean I've
seen it in operation and the Maldives
because all the the entire water supply
come on every island comes from
desalination and naturally that's done
using diesel generators which is about
the worst possible option and it's
actually quite compatible with
renewables but
you can attach solar farms to desal and
you can store the water and it doesn't
matter if the Sun goes in for a few
minutes whereas it does if you're trying
to run a grid the whole time
so it sounds like you're not against
renewables wind and solar what forms of
it are you need founders dog in the UK
context I'm a big advocate of offshore
wind and we've got a lot we've got I
think it's five or six gigawatts of that
now around the shores and there what is
wrong in this country where is your
office or wind did Bobby Kennedy stop it
or ever it was yeah
Nantucket Sound look like a good site
but you know yeah this is like you know
they say with the Saudi Arabia of wind
but you know you've got to develop wind
as part of an integrated grid which can
export and import between very large
areas due to the intermittency problem
and I think a sensible energy path for
the UK involves about 30 40 % winds 30
40 % nuclear and a few other bits and
pieces I take it you're not the solar
energy I think we you know I think
there's a role for PV even and even in
the UK but probably less than 10 percent
and and and that's if you've got solar
panels in every single roof you know
that's what the Germans are going for
and working for the Germans well they've
spent potentially - 300 billion going
forward in terms of the commitments for
the feed-in tariffs and they've probably
got three percent I think of energy of
electricity from solar so that's about a
Fukushima they get 17% no I'm sorry 23%
of their electricity from nuclear they
used to anymore no I mean German co2
emissions have gone up a lot but
remember the German and the European
economy is capped by the emissions
trading system so the German emissions
can't go up without them having to buy
emissions permits or somewhere else so
actually having that regulatory
structure has helped and it's gone it's
not there in it in Japan and Japan's
gonna burn it they're importing huge
amounts more LNG and oil they even burn
liquid oil and coal as well so the
alternatives in the short term to
nuclear really are only fossil the
argument is over the very long term
whether you can do whether you can phase
out nuclear replace it with renewables
but if you do that you only stand still
and remember we need to decarbonize the
grid urgently for all these reasons how
much solar in North Africa and North or
North Africa light up Europe if we want
to
very energy insecure in the Europe and I
think that's a politically an issue
given that the whole reason to turn off
gas is so the Russians don't hold Europe
to ransom right you know imagine if
there's a revolution in Algeria they
don't just don't have to turn off the
tap they just have to flick a switch and
we would plunge Germany into darkness
you know but it's a problem politically
because people are concerned about these
things and but I think using very large
scale solar thermal you could get twenty
percent of Europe's electricity probably
but there are problems you need water
how do you generate thermal electricity
in the desert so this challenge is there
I think it will be big but it's it's not
easy either
I like NASA North Africa also Australia
just goes there mineral deserts and
mineral deserts personally I'm okay with
lots and lots of stuff on the wine
scheme James costs as a question no
deaths from nuclear waste how about the
plutonium scattered around Hanford
Washington what about it well not that
scientifically valid I don't think means
physicians for Social Responsibility is
Helen cold accosting and I don't
having said having seen the kind of
garbage that they put out I don't know
about this case and I can't comment
about it but plutonium remember I was
talking about this was true earlier on
remember back when was it in the 80s
when Bernhard Cohen challenged Ralph
Nader to he said I will eat as much
plutonium as you'll eat caffeine you
will die and I will survive lutonium is
not very hard to find micrograms of
plutonium well I mean if you say there's
dust plutonium dust floating on this
place that's certainly not a good idea
I will agree with you that but I don't
think it's a you know it's not a huge
driver of biodiversity loss in any place
which is the point I was making I think
nuclear radiation and nuclear waste and
these things absolutely needs to be
properly safeguarded and it's a health
and safety issue for humans there's no
doubt about that here's question James L
Jim L why do you think the opposition of
GM
so much more widespread in Europe than
in the US when the Europeans have an
ethical edge on the u.s. usually I you
know I take a small measure of personal
responsibility for that I helped start
off the anti GMO movement in the UK you
started it
not personal well I mean I was I was
probably there in the first one of the
first meetings with Greenpeace and
everyone else and we thought we were
outraged about what Monsanto was doing
about the scariness of this new
technology and we were determined to
stop it
this was 1980s when about 1995 and um
and we succeeded by and large by all
sorts of different strategies putting
labeling things in supermarkets scaring
people with Frankenstein foods going and
digging their things up and we now have
a regulatory environment in Europe which
makes it almost impossible fact it makes
it impossible to commercialize GMOs and
one of the reason for that one of the
impacts of that is the only the very
biggest corporations can now Cadell get
in in on this business because it costs
100 million to get through the
regulatory process so you know your
garage biotech or even your public
sector research companies can't do this
Rothamsted down the road and from new
Gotham stead is the one of the greatest
agricultural research entities in the
world they've been going in for 150
years now or something
yeah and and they're doing public sector
GMOs they're doing wheat which is going
to be drought resistance and disease
resistant there's all sorts of new
diseases which are a real problem in a
monocultural agricultural situation
where there are disease resistant
varieties which are GM which you can't
take outside the laboratory because it's
they're legal but one day those might
need to be put across huge areas in
order to save the world from a massive
disease outbreak in food crops which
we're about to have with wheat Kevin
Kelly asks a kind of a general question
is a stable climate and the whole of
scene a precedent to civilization or a
consequence of civilization or is there
some kind of co-evolutionary
relationship between there's stable
climate and the civilization oh that's a
huge debate about that I mean there's
some there's there's a perspective that
suggests that when humans first started
doing agriculture that released more
carbon and methane and that stopped the
world
lipping the temperature slipping
downwards I think it's bill Ruddiman who
came up with that and but III don't know
I mean I don't think we can we don't
know what the hypothetical situation
what would have happened otherwise is
going to be but yeah there's got to be
coevolution between the very stable
temperatures and the emergence of human
civilization I can't imagine you know
you look at the the sheer I mean
obviously this is a hundred thousand
year time scale but it's very rapid the
changes between and they're four or five
degrees changes on in the global average
which happening within probably within
decades so one of the fears that sort of
emerged with climate research in the
last 15-20 years is that as you say
occasionally things happen quickly
you've been a climber reporter now for
quite a while what are your abrupt
climate change fears I think there's
some misnomers about this right okay
can't get the planet can't on average
gain heat that quickly you can't go you
can't have a tipping point to get
suddenly four or five degrees warmer in
a year or two because the heats got to
come from somewhere what happens is the
distribution of heat within the Earth's
system changes and if this is what
happens in an El Nino year is that a lot
of heat comes out of the Pacific Ocean
is released into the atmosphere that
raises global temperatures and it
changes world weather patterns and
that's what that's what has been behind
some of the abrupt changes before was
the simple reorganization of the system
what winds blow where and you can see
from the Greenland ice core that happens
would from one year to the next
you know the entire circulation pattern
has a normal Northern Hemisphere change
isn't it it scares me a little bit what
we're doing to the Arctic sea ice how
rapidly that's disappearing because
that's already probably having an impact
it's making a snowier in the winter in
the northern hemisphere - do you have to
damn near a blizzard in London in this
winter last the last two winters were
much colder and snowier than and you
know it makes sense because of the
pressure circulation of the the lower
atmosphere so there's that the models
are now beginning to explain why this is
even happening so we are reorganizing
the atmospheric circulation over a very
wide scale by changing the energy
balance of that the planetary surface
and so these are the kinds of things
which I think we need to keep keep very
close tougher so you know you'll get the
thing all climate people yeah okay we
were having weird snow and
we're having a persistent drought in
Texas is this climate or is this whether
it's weather okay
how do we know when it's climate when it
happens for 30 years in a row changes
they're very conservative Snyder's told
me 10 years and it starts to be climate
30 so by the time we've been timer sure
it's too late that's the situation yeah
you waiting first happen well I am
actually you've seen moods come and go
on climate you know the political
discourse is all over the place
the climatologists that I know and
probably the ones you know we're kind of
in despair over the last few years
because they thought that they would get
the word out and people who say gosh
thanks for this information that will
now act on it
and rather they don't act on it and see
they want to pretend that the
information isn't real what's the state
of that how does how does how is climate
playing out politically you've been at
Durban you've been in the thick of this
stuff how do you think climate plays out
politically over time I think we've got
to do something new in terms of the
politics something new in terms of
politics I think we need to do something
new in terms of the politics I mean the
climate culture wars is just has got
into a state of trench warfare that it's
worse than just song it's like abortion
or something yeah I don't know what I
don't know what it is it's just I can't
see that being tractable I can't see
people changing sides even the
scientists are now getting involved in
the in the dirt of you know of defending
the reality of climate change but we've
got if we're going to solve climate
change we're gonna have to take the
other side with us in some way which is
one of the reasons why I like nuclear
because the the skeptics are all
pro-nuclear the Republican Party's
all-pro nuclear the other side's all-pro
climate and actually doing nuclear would
sort help solve that problem and that's
probably the only area of convergence I
can ever think of
is that working
real working yet or anywhere else hope
that I keep you I'm having some of these
techno fixes GM and nuclear and many
others coming along
is that there seems to be more action on
them in developing countries like China
India parts of Latin America parts of
Africa then in the so-called developed
countries like Europe and North America
do you see that I mean it's a problem
for nuclear that you can't actually
build anything in the US or in Europe
anymore because it takes too long to get
through the regulatory process you know
in Europe that you can't even you can't
do GMOs that's why BASF left they up
their whole headquarters and moved into
Canada and because you simply can't the
political environment is not conducive
to regulatory void it's not reducing to
do anything new you can't do a
large-scale project so it's going to be
in China it's going to be in South Korea
I mean we're the first integral fast
reactor is going to be it's not I doubt
it's going to be in America mm-hmm it's
gonna be in Russia or China or somewhere
else where they can do things quickly
and you can still you know you're gonna
get it wrong the first time we're gonna
have to improve technologies you know
it's not that scary it doesn't have to
be absolutely right spot-on first time
although they did actually and have a
meltdown in one of them and it was all
right I'm early on in the experiment oh
there's been tons of meltdowns and all
these things and that's what you learned
from you know you learn from mistakes
and and a nuclear meltdown doesn't have
to be or isn't Armageddon as we can see
from Fukushima and there's good things
about these these offices worst-case
scenarios happenings that we can learn
from them we can see what the worst case
scenario is and rather than it being
some kind of unspeakable shadowy
Armageddon type fear we can actually
quantify it very precisely what the
impacts of it are well it the pressure
seemed to me out of Fukushima three
simultaneous meltdowns right next to
each other that's about this worst-case
scenarios you get oh my god how many
people died and it looks like nobody
died and I assume there's not there's a
time twenty thousand people died but not
from the meltdowns no and actually you
see the pictures of the tsunami damage
and the death tolls and then is a it's
all about nuclear and I think even at a
subconscious level these things are too
far to intertangled
because well why were there no nuclear
yes whereas there were Chernobyl quite a
few and my sense is that the knowledge
is so good on what acute doses of
radiation what the mouths of acute doses
radiation can do to you that they were
able to basically monitor and valve the
people going in and out of the reactor
sites to work on the meltdown try to
cool it down and all the rest of it and
therefore we're not getting anybody
overexposed well he didn't have a I mean
you didn't have a total failure of
containment in Chernobyl there was no
containment structure and and and there
was a steam explosion the graphite
caught fire and it burnt for I think 10
days the scattering radiation absolutely
everywhere right so you there wasn't you
know there was bits of burning core you
know from hundreds of yards all around
the place on the roofs of other
buildings you couldn't get you know
that's why people died the operators
died and in in Fukushima the operators
were terrified for their lives and they
were asked by TEPCO who was going to
volunteer to stay and everyone put the
hands up because that was the kind of
solidarity that people had they knew had
they had to solve this problem I
couldn't like that when the older
engineers said send me yeah you know if
I get cancer in 30 years so what I would
die there something else 20 years before
that yeah nice use of old people going
you're gonna join the queue absolutely I
mean even you know we know fairly
precisely what the doses are but even
the most heavily exposed work has got
and it's it's well below any kind of
health impact which is visible now and
statistically they will have a small
increase probably in there in the
chances of them developing cancer but
even if you look back at the chernobyl
Liquidators so that several hundred
thousand people who helped clear up
shoveling up the mess and got very heavy
doses there's still no evidence of
increased cancer and so the evidence is
probably going to be so small that
you'll never be able to see it and
that's the case for the general public
as well whether that's a good thing or a
bad thing I wouldn't say that the
increase isn't going to be there because
we simply don't know but if you can
never see it there's a lot of other
things which happen which are worse
right people certificate on automobile
accidents from air pollution like I said
earlier on we've got to address risk in
a
fortunate way across all of the
different areas where it comes up so
you're and you've been living in London
some of the time which is this dangerous
place as he was playing you know your
gulps potox is way worse oh and now
you're off to the Fukushima exclusion
zone just you're going there for your
health all right you know when I was in
Chernobyl mm-hmm I probably picked up a
bit of a dose so I'm I'm concerned
enough about it to go and to go and be
there yeah and I would I don't think you
allowed into most of the exclusion zone
but it's just it's a funny thing that
it's so psychosomatic I was told a story
about one of the UN workers who was
doing the helping with the original
reports on Chernobyl and he was he was
in the zone for two or three days and he
had this awful leaden feeling in his
bones and he could hardly move and you
know they thought my god what's happened
it's got to be something and actually
what happened is he hadn't had a proper
coffee for three days he was having a
caffeine withdrawal because the
Ukrainian coffee is just such crap
starving so pretty odd and Chernobyl are
becoming a tourist attraction you've
you've been one there and I've seen
photographs now lots of people there
doing stuff and you approve of that okay
but people disapprove but Pripyat blew
my mind I mean you
this place is frozen in time in April
1986 they were about to do the May Day
Parade which happens on May the first
and they've got all these huge portraits
of the Soviet there are Soviet leaders
in the Politburo all stacked up and
behind this gymnasium the gymnasium next
door has got a tree growing through the
floor you know there's there's wildlife
everywhere the kindergartens were you
know there's schoolbooks left all over
the place they've got a big Stalin Lenin
worship corner you know where else in
the former Soviet Union can you see this
stuff it's all been taken down and and
yet people can walk in that people are
spraying graffiti on it people are
damaging it now I think this needs to be
a World Heritage Site UNESCO should get
involved in preservers because it's such
an extraordinary place it's a nice
approach
so in GMOs go amateur which I've been
proclaiming for a while because
everything else biotech is going amateur
pretty quickly and in their garden sheds
at the bottom of the garden in England
people are making cabbages that blow
your mind and do not ask permission of
Syngenta or any of the other or they
call him jean giants are you worried
about that I'm more worried than I would
be about any other kind of genetic
interference in crops I mean in the old
days they used to blast them with
radiation and induce all sorts of
mutations they're still doing what
happens how we breed them absolutely and
you know you're you're messing with a
whole a whole lot of the genome doing
that at least GM tends to be much more
precise in terms of you stick the
particular gene that you want in a
particular place you want it to go and
then it has that expression and so I
don't think you don't mind eating
cabbage the glows in the dark a little
bit of a jellyfish in there nope the
fact I'm when I was in Oregon and just
last week and I went up with Steve
Straus from the forestry department and
saw his GM poplars and friends of mine
were instrumental in destroying his
colleagues test site in the UK and they
destroyed that man's life life's work
and what did you say to him I I was
actually for once in my life almost
speechless he invited you thoroughly
yeah and some but you know these look
like normal trees to me of course
they're you may know a loose in China
they have a lot of BT poplars English
poplars bless your heart scattered all
over China and they are presumably
sharing their genes with the natural
poplars such as they are there well I
mean they will if it's an evolutionary
if there's a selective advantage if
there's some selective advantage in them
then genes may flow
I mean poplar I think is windblown
pollen and it goes for a long way in
fact what Steve's doing is them trying
to develop sterile varieties which will
only be cloned and because then you
don't have any gene flow Terminator
poplars Oh exactly
that was that was designed of course to
address the problem of gene flow and to
say well you can have a organic field
right next to it and there won't be any
contamination it's not a problem then it
became this great big thing where you
were trying to wipe out the world's
population but you know that that comes
from it comes from misunderstanding and
the biggest misunderstanding of all is
that genes will only transfer if there's
selective advantage in them doing so and
most of what we do in GM is simply
applicable in the very domesticated
environment you know these are these are
useless pathetic plants unless we're
farming them they're not gonna go
anywhere I mean herbicide tolerance
there's no advantage unless you're being
sprayed with herbicide these super weeds
aren't going to take over the native
woodland next-door are they know they're
they're specialized it's the wrong thing
[Laughter]
though they are going along the highways
which also use herbicides
so yeah okay what we're environmentalist
write about all along and still are
let's finish for that you're still
agreeing I'm still a green we've flipped
down a couple of things but I mean the
planetary boundaries is a very
environmentalist narrative and that's
why I find it attractive because it's
talking about protecting the living
resilient quality of the biosphere for
as long as we possibly can from bad
human interventions right we know what
we can figure out using the planetary
boundaries what interventions make sense
in which ones don't
so all the boundaries that article and
its many authors and now you spoke about
or all boundaries are being pushed by
human activities is that right yeah yeah
are there boundaries that may come to
pass anyway that are not pushed by human
activities but we may want to take some
ameliorative action on we seem to like
this table you like an impact of a
meteorite or something that comes to
mind yeah and who knows I mean it's it's
a it's a planetary boundaries 1.0 so
there's going to be a 2 and a 3 and a
3.4 and you know it's going to it's
going to be work in progress and there's
all sorts of ways in which you can you
can criticize the BET the basis of it
even from you know particularly from a
scientific perspective so I don't think
it's it's perfect in a sense
by any stretch of the imagination but
it's just really useful if you want to
say what do I think about x y&z
structured along the planter boundaries
and I think you'll come up with a more
environmental type result and you would
have done otherwise
okay there's a fundamental problem
politics often runs on a nice clear
story a political agenda which one then
sort of swears a certain allegiance to
you and sticks by and hangs within as
loyal to century you and you haven't
been anyway a year after year decade
after decade and that's how you get
political actions by a lot of people
agreeing and moving as one in a certain
direction you want this kind of
science-based environmental activity
it's not gonna be a movement because
science is just this big long argument
no I which keeps changing new data comes
in you know they change the models and
what's a true believer supposed to do
with that if I could ask for something I
would ask for a slightly more rational
environmentalism right I don't think
environmentalism has got everything
wrong in terms of the you know what
people feel and the passions that people
feel about protecting the planet I think
those are absolutely spot-on but you
don't do that by taking a position which
is completely the opposite of what all
what pretty much all scientists are
saying and so it's got to be empirical
it's got to be evidence-based it's got
to be modern the fraud is a better way
of putting it yeah I mean so just got to
keep change it's gotta change you can't
have a fixed ideology otherwise you turn
to al-qaeda thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you